you have two fractions one four and five
six and you want to rewrite them so they
have the same denominator and have whole
number numerators what numbers could you
use for the denominator so here's our
fractions 1/4 and 5/6 and we want to
rewrite these fractions to have new
denominators so we currently have a 4
and a 6 as our denominator and can we
just be any newton thing like maybe 5
could we say let's change them both to
have 5 is the denominator the answer is
no we have to pick a multiple of 4 and 6
a multiple some number that we can
multiply 4 and get this number as an
answer so for example 4 for some
multiples of 4 would be 4 times 1 is 4 4
times 2 is 8 4 times 3 is 12 and so on
those are multiples of 4 and let's just
pause here and look at why we have to
pick a multiple of 4 and 6 why we can't
just pick any number but we have to pick
a multiple of our denominators so the
fraction we were just talking about was
1/4 we could look at either one but
let's look at 1/4 here we have a picture
showing fourths and to show 1/4 we shade
one of these 4 equal sized pieces well
maybe I want to change this and I want
to say I want to I want to is my
numerator so to have a numerator of 2
I'm going to need to split this fourth
up here into two pieces now I have two
shaded pieces so can I say this is 2 1 2
out of 1 2 3 4 5 pieces
it's not 2/5 because these are not equal
size pieces so if I split this forth
right here in half I need to split all
of them in half and what I'm doing is
doubling the amount of pieces so now
this is 2 pieces this is 2
and this is two because we need equal
sized pieces so now this is one two
pieces out of one two three four five
six seven eight equal sized pieces so
two eight and you can see eight is a
multiple of four because we multiplied
by two and that's what we did we
multiplied each of our pieces by two we
also multiply our numerator by 2 because
that was also doubled the amount of
shaded pieces doubled when the entire
amount of pieces doubled and we don't
have to do this just with two we could
do any multiple for for example we can
do one more here if we again let's shade
one-fourth
one of the four pieces and maybe this
time we want to split it into three
equal sized pieces
so to have a new numerator of three and
these should be equal sized here's a
numerator of three but it's we can't do
our denominator yet because we don't
have equal sized pieces so to get equal
sized pieces we'll need to split each of
these fourths into three so we are
tripling the amount of pieces so now we
have three shaded pieces out of a total
of 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 out of 12
and I could have figured that out
without even counting because I knew
that we tripled this time we multiplied
our original denominator times 3 we
tripled and we also multiply our
numerator times 3 so these are the
multiples 8 12 and so on and so those
are the denominators we can pick
something that we can multiply our
denominator by so we can multiply the
entire amount of pieces and again so
this is super clear one fourth and two
eighths and three twelfths they all
represent the same amount
whether we had 1/4 the original here's
to AIDS 312 they're all equivalent they
all represent the same amount they're
just different ways of writing the same
number back to our original question
what denominators can we use 4/4 and 4
sixths well we know we need to use
multiples so let's look at the multiples
for 4 we've already gone through some of
these the first multiple of 4 is 4 times
1 which is 4 second multiple of 4 is 8 4
times 2 is 8 so we could split our
fourth Cinda in half and get eighths or
we could say 4 times 3 is 12 which we
showed again where we split our fourth
seat each fourth into three equal pieces
or we could do 4 times 4 which is 16 4
times 5 is 20 4 times 6 is 24 and so on
the reason I'm stopping at 24 is I've
looked at my answer choices and I can
see the largest possible answer is 24 so
I don't need to write any larger
multiples there are many many many more
multiples of 4 but we don't need to list
them all because the largest number
we're going to can have to consider is
24 let's do the same for 6 we could
leave our sixths alone 6 times 1 and
keep 6 pieces or we could double our 6 6
times 2 would be 12 if we doubled the
pieces we would have 12 pieces we could
say 6 times 3 which is 18 or 6 times 4
we could divide each of our sixths into
4 pieces and we'd have 6 times 4 which
is 24 or twenty-fourths and so on again
I'll stop at 24 since it's the largest
number we need to consider so down to
our answer choices
what numbers could we use for the
denominator could we use 8 let's look at
these lists 8 is a multiple of 4 so we
could definitely split fourths into
eighths but 8 is not a multiple of 6 so
we cannot split 6 into eighths so 8 will
not work as a denominator for both
actions how about 12 12 we can see is a
multiple of four and we showed that we
drew that already and 12 is a multiple
of six we could split our six into two
equal pieces each and we would have
twelfths
so twelve does work twelve is a
denominator a common denominator 4/4 and
six 18 18 is here on the sixth we could
split six into 18 because 18 is a
multiple of six but it is not a multiple
of four so we can rule out 18 18 is not
a common denominator and 24 you may
remember was the last number we wrote on
both of them so yes 24 could be a
denominator 4/4 and 6 so we could use
either 12 or 24 and there's a lot more
numbers we could use two as common
denominators but from these choices we
could use 12 or 24 as a common
denominator 4/4 and 6 it's just a note
lots of times people like to use the
smallest one the least common
denominator which in this case is 12 and
it makes a lot of sense because it's
easier to do computation with smaller
numbers but you don't absolutely have to
use the smallest one you could use 12s
or 24th soar or lots of other options
but again 12 says probably the simplest
one to work with just because generally
it's easier to work with smaller numbers
but for this question the common
denominators we can use from these
choices 4/4 and 6 are 12 and 24